the return of Chris Evans as Captain
America Robert Downey Jr as Iron Man and
Scarlett Johansson as Black Widow is
something that everybody has been
talking about for some time now since it
was revealed that phase four five and
six of the MCU were the Multiverse Saga
and since it was revealed that the last
movie of the Multiverse Saga would be
Avengers Secret Wars fans have been
speculating about these iconic actors
returning to their iconic characters and
yes this is reportedly going to happen
in Avengers Secret Wars but what could
possibly be even more exciting than that
is the reports of The Nomad project that
we've been getting for some time now now
if you're not familiar with what the
Nomad project is this could be a project
where we see Robert Downey Jr Chris
Evans and Scarlett Johansson return not
as variance of the characters that they
used to play but as the actual
characters now right off the bat some of
of you might be asking well aren't they
dead well at least two of them are dead
we're unclear of what really happened
with Chris Evans as Captain America
Steve Rogers at this point he really
could be on the moon for all we know or
he could still be alive or he could have
passed away due to old age but main
point aren't these characters gone and
the answer is yes however the Nomad
project would take place before phase 4
for those unfamiliar with the Nomad
project it would be a project about
Steve Rogers turning the Infinity Stones
to where they got them there is a huge
story to tell that we never got at the
end of Avengers endgame we saw Chris
Evans as Captain America go back in time
to return the stones and we saw him come
back but of course as everybody knows
when he came back he lived a full life a
life that we never saw and never really
even heard about besides the fact that
he went back and he married Peggy and
fans have been dying to know what
exactly happened when he returned the
stones well that's what the Nomad
project is believed by many to be about
if it happens recently some people
believe that the project was scrapped
and is never going to be made however
we've been given a dim Light Of Hope in
fact based off of recent activity from
Marvel Studios and Disney it looks like
there is quite a bit of hope that this
project could actually be made and we'll
go over what you need to know but quick
reminder only one day left of the
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items all you have to do is
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below we pick one winner at
the end of each month and the winner
gets to pick one item today the last day
for this month and we will start the
giveaway again next year as well now the
Nomad story in the comics is very
different than what is believed to be
the story of The Nomad MCU project there
have been several people who have had
the Nomad title in Marvel Comics but the
original one is Steve Rogers and Captain
America number 180 December 1974 Steve
Rogers becomes disillusioned with the
United States government and realizes
that he cannot trust them anymore he
discovers that a very high ranking
government official is the leader of the
terrorist organization known as the
secret Empire and he believes that it is
actually the president at that time
Richard Nixon as it's heavily hinted at
is the leader of that secret Empire so
then Steve Rogers then decides to
abandon his identity as Captain America
he is Captain America no more but then a
runin with Hawkeye who was disguised as
the golden archer makes him realize that
he can't just quit the life of a hero so
he dons a new suit with no patriotic
marks on them and he becomes Nomad
however he's not Nomad for very long and
he quickly goes back to being Captain
America deciding he could help his
Nation without blindly supporting his
government so that specific story
probably doesn't have a place in the MCU
right now as we know it I mean we
basically kind of already got the nomad
M Captain America after the events of
Civil War took place with Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers endgame and it
is possible that they could dive a
little bit into that story as well since
it does involve Black Widow they could
go on and tell us about the events that
took place between Civil War and
infinity war and show us what Steve
Rogers Sam Wilson and black widow were
up to as well as the Scarlet Witch in
fact I think it would be kind of a Miss
opportunity if they didn't at least show
us some of what happened during that
time now they did do a tie-in comic that
did show us a little bit about this and
this was years and years ago right
around the time of infinity War but it's
widely believed that this story if it
gets made would be about Steve Rogers
returning the stones and would be about
his life after he did that basically
what we never saw that we really want to
see and here's the really cool thing
about this about 3 years ago Marvel
Studios actually trademark the name
Nomad they trademarked Marvel Studios
Nomad now they trademarked that
alongside of secret Invasion iron heart
and armor Wars and all of those projects
were revealed however Nomad wasn't it
was speculated that they would get Chris
Evans Robert Downey Jr and Scarlett
Johansson to return however since they
just finished Avengers endgame they
wanted a little bit more time a little
bit of a break between the biggest movie
of all time at least it was until the
re-release of Avatar and a new project
where they would return probably for one
last time as their iconic characters
however like I mentioned it's been about
3 years and nothing has really come up
about this project that is until the
beginning of this month we got a little
update about the Nomad project and this
was discovered by Charles Murphy at
Murphy Multiverse tocom and they found
out that when Marvel Studios trademarks
upcoming projects they file multiple
different trademarks some are for toys
some are for clothing some are for cups
Etc other types of merchandise however
they also file one for entertainment
services which essentially indicates
that they are making either a film or a
TV series now this is what they did 3
years ago alongside armor Wars and
secret Invasion Etc but here's the
interesting part as for everything else
that Marvel Studios does they filed one
of these entertainment services
trademarks for nomad and Charles Murphy
recently discovered that Marvel Studios
let all of these other trademarks die
for nomad except the entertainment
services one in fact it's been
discovered that the studio has actually
taken measures to extend the trademark
on several occasions including very
recently so this means at least for the
time being the project is still alive
and Marvel has not scrapped it yet and
in fact many insiders have reported that
Robert Downey Jr and Chris Evans and
Scarlett Johansson are indeed returning
for Secret Wars that means Marvel
Studios has met with them already to
talk about them returning and if this is
still a go that means they most likely
talk to them about the Nomad project yes
we believe that it will most likely
focus on captain in America however they
would be foolish not to include Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man and Scarlett
Johansson's Black Widow in fact it's
actually widely believed that Scarlett
Johansson is going to direct this film
it's already been confirmed and this was
a little bit ago that Scarlett Johansson
was indeed returning to Marvel Studios
to direct a project she wanted to direct
and produce and what better project to
direct or produce than this project one
where she could also reprise her role as
Black Widow and not just as a variant
but as the same character that she and
it'll actually be pretty interesting for
these characters because at the end when
Captain America went to return the
stones they had already died but Captain
America does have to return the stones
to where they were taken from one of
which would have to be when he was time
traveling with Tony Stark and the other
would have to be where Natasha
sacrificed herself and vormir so he
could run into both of them then but
like I mentioned it would also be really
cool if they showed some of what
happened between Civil War and infinity
war and endgame that time where
basically Captain America and Black
Widow were Outlaw which was basically
The Nomad story that we didn't get to
see but either way it would be something
truly exciting to see even just seeing
Chris Evans returning as Captain America
Robert Downey Jr returning as Iron Man
and Scarlet Johansson returning as Black
Widow that is just simply enough to
watch anything that they could be a part
of but the fact that we have a really
awesome story that is sitting right
there that could be told that we have
never seen before makes it even more
exciting so I hope this project gets
made so let me know your thoughts about
this in the comments down below what
would you like the story to be and would
you be excited to see all of these
characters return please don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date on the MCU and a big happy New
Year's to everybody hope 2024 is a great
one and better than 2023 for everybody
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof